bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur del
tonale tv pour suivre les matchs retour
de ces demi finales du championnat du
monde féminin 2015 demi finale qui voit
s'affronter d'un côté la russe natalya
pogonat face à la suédoise pia cramer
ling et dans le trash
l'indienne arica qui fait face à
l'ukrainienne musi tchouk dans l'autre
demi-finale les donc les les joueuses
sont à égalité après leur match nul donc
match nul les amènera directement au tie
break
on va voir cette première demi finale
qui semble la plus tendue puisque pogo
nina est mené 1 0 après la première
partie mais allez blanc pour revenir et
on sait on a vu dans ce championnat du
monde que pour une inna est revenu deux
fois en huitièmes et en quarts de finale
face à marie sebag puis face à la
chinoise de souza au elle est revenue
deux fois et avec les noirs et puis face
à toulouse a volé aussi revenu en partie
rapide
on a vu que donc c'était c'est son truc
de revenir à la 2e donc on va voir ce
que ça donne
après ici le début de partie qui est de
4 c 5 noeuds la part de pékin craint
ming donc sicilienne qui arrive 3 à 6
alors ça c'est un peu étonnant parce
qu'on joue à six bons joue pas pour le
centre on peut rien en général on joue
il ya d'autres courent on peut mettre
les cavaliers ou alors on peut jouer des
6,6 pour jouer vers le centre mais là
c'est un coup de côté bon
mais c'est dans l'idée la sicilienne
après fou et 2e 6 x 2 aussi d'un coup un
peu d'attentes on en peut jouer des
capots 6 alors ça c'est une sicilienne
je crois qu'ils s'appellent kahn s'il n'
cannes particulièrement on n'a pas sorti
les cavaliers encore ayant joué avec eux
6 et 1 6 2 6 6 1 6 6 il ya deux types
cannes voilà des quatre s'éprend des
quatre cavaliers prend des quatre
califes si ce qu'a laissé trois ans
protègent le cloud à tout ça est normal
mais regardez alors pourquoi on joue
aussi ce regard des boum on joue au foot
de 4 le club élite louis voilà donc le
piouf 4 est en prison peut faire cavaler
prend 1,4 si les blancs ne faut rien
donc on joue ici 1,5 sans doute le mieux
il n'y a pas de moyen efficace de
protéger ce pion et en plus on veut
profiter du fait que les pions noirs
justement n'ont pas bougé le pion des
six est toujours là pour jouer au 5
si on attend les noirs joueront
peut-être des 6 et on pourra plus le
faire après donc que 5 on essaie de
profiter d'un affaiblissement des
classes noir côté noire implique on le
voit aller tous les pions sont sur blanc
qu'à valider cinq alors attention
maintenant lecavalier était cloué mais
en plus on va pouvoir le prendre en
doublant les pions blancs alors on
pourrait protéger mais ça empêcherait
pas le doublement donc là les blancs
font une variante simplement une rock
voilà ils n'ont pas peur de la prise en
c3 qui on prend qui ont doublé alors les
noirs ici pourrait prendre en main en c3
c'est parce qu'ils vont faire on va voir
où c'est possible mais si on prend un c3
sans doute tombé aux mains sûres pour
éviter la prise de la tour commence à
faire pression sur un bessette pas
facile et sûre petit rock on joue tour
b3 le flou et on va en g3 on va h trois
ans visant le rock avec des jeunes
pièces lourdes adam va arriver très
forte attaque et non n'en veulent pas et
je vous fais e set mais dans ce cas là
les blancs continuent leur développement
ou f4 protège 2,5 donc la pression sur
cases noires semblent existe petit rock
comme détroit
regardez ici côté noir tout ça c'est
quand même sur la deuxième le fou c'est
8 et le cavaly ses huit ne sont pas
sorties donc l'avantagé blanc ici
consiste au fait que tout est sorti les
tours sont liés et pièces sont déjà
positionnés la dame des trois temps plus
qu'une chose c'est de coulisses et
angers 3 ou 1 h 3 classique pour viser
le rock on va essayer d'affaiblir ce
rock et de monter une attaque et noir
ont pour avantage d'avoir à long terme
si une finale si on enlevait tout ici
sont gagnants parce que là on a deux
pions doubler la colonne c'est aux mines
tours là on ramasse tout donc à long
terme la position blanche et mauvaise
donc c'est le problème si la structure
des pions blancs mais entre le début de
partie et la finale comme disait l'autre
les dieux en place et le milieu de jeu
heureusement c'est à dire que tout est
encore possible bien sûr et l'idée de ce
début c'est donc cette attaque b6 alors
vu que au centre c'est difficile
d'envisager d'avancé parce que les
blancs contrôle très bien la classe des
six avec il ya peu avoir des menaces
pénible ça peut très embêtant veut jouer
b6 pour mettre le fou en baisse est donc
ici simplement faux h 3o godina attaque
la tour en trois sets ont tout prévu et
sur fouet 4 qui commence à programme
menacé bien phu price est évidemment il
faut faire quelque chose j'ai 6 voilà
j'ai six très bien et la tour f b 1 or
doivent d un bon alors aussi bien on
aurait pu aussi jouer sans doute tour à
b1 pour commencer à attaquer le pian b6
aussi que même s'il est défendu mais on
commence à mettre de la pression dessus
et puis on a vu que cette tour alors a
vécu d'une chose c'est d'envisager de de
se joindre à la bataille contre le roi à
certains cas on pourrait jouer tomber
trois aussi pour et on aurait pu relayer
doubler les tours sur b6 est aussi
d'envisager plus tard c4 et la tourbe
peut coulisser par exemple en h3 pour
viser h7
vous de cette vous prend pour prendre
hélas tombé 1 voilà ça y est maintenant
pu faire avant tout mais aussi
commencent à faire petite pression sur
le plan des six courses dames c'est 8
on peut aussi en maintenant trouver 3 2
comme ça à 4 toujours pareil pression
sur b6 sur bessèges simplement ben et
tout on perd un pur enfin en tout cas on
perd le pion bellay noire pour se venger
sur le pion c'est après il faut calculer
ce que ça donne dames c'est celle qui
est là comme les baies 3 attaque la dame
et lui dis où tu vas il a minci tu viens
on décèle probablement échange des dames
et on prend simplement gagner un pion
let
et puis sinon mais la dame a pas trop le
choix lorsqu'elle rentre à la maison
voilà elle revient en c7 est maintenant
qu'à valider deux très jolis cette
manoeuvre
elle a attendu ici pogo ninacs la dame
jour on joue qu'à iv 3d gain de temps
sur adam tan cavaliers d2 l'idée c'est
qu'on a une magnifique kazan rus kat qui
sont mieux que dans des cas puisqu'en
aux quatre ont balisé la casse faible f6
avec un échec possible même si le fou
veille bien sûr il faut voir si c'est
intéressant mais on vise aussi la casse
décision renforce le contrôle et donc on
a une cavale et blanc centralisée très
très bien placé qu'avait laissé six les
noirs finissent leur développement et la
belle et le problème c'est que ça donne
le pion à 6 alors si les blancs avaient
pris le pion à 6 c'est ce qui est
envisageable
ici
et noir on aurait pu bien sûr c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'elle n'a pas fait
prendre le pion au 5 mai ça marche pas
puisque sur flu prendre dans prend il ya
la tour qui est perdu voilà donc c'était
envisageable de faire d'un prend 1,6
mais peut-être que dans prend assise
permet au noir simplement de jouer tour
bessette et après ici par exemple dans
le ccap pour continuer de protéger de
protéger à 4 en double les tours et les
blancs un problème sur à quatre avec des
tours qui rentrent en jeu des tours qui
en plus seront sur cette quatrième
colonne donc rendront la tâche plus
difficile parce que cette tour va
pouvoir exercer une défense latérale
voilà donc c'est une autre variante qui
est possible mais qui changent la
structure de la partie
donc après qu'avait laissé 6 on prend
pas le pion à 6,90 elle joue pogo nina
d'alger 3 pourquoi pas je continue
d'exercer une protection maximale sur
scène qui attention le club allait quand
même attaqué cinq ou six et les noirs
jouent simplement tour c'est 8
voilà on positionne c'est ce qu'on a
lissé l'avantagent noir les pièces
bourne sur la colonne ses expositions
semble assez équilibré mais après 4 on
voit bien que les blancs quand même sont
bien l'attaqué peut être forte le cas
les magnifiques il protège ses trois
donc ça c'est un problème définitivement
réglé on pourra pas prendre les pieds ce
lourd discipline plus légère qui défend
et le câble et là il n'est pas près de
pouvoir attaquer ces trois nient le fou
d'ailleurs on voit pas bien comment ils
forêt pour aller attaquer ces 30
donc ça c'est solide qu'elle allait aux
4es et sur sa meilleure case contrôle
des six contrôles et 6
pourquoi pas plus tard pour aller angers
5 donc il est très bien ce collier après
maintenant on va pouvoir jouer h 4 h 5
chose comme ça pour essayer d'affaiblir
le rock
si les noirs jouent h5 eux mêmes ils
s'affaiblissent quand même le rock on
peut envisager après des sacrifices sur
g6 il reste à mener une tour d' attaque
mais elles peuvent venir en attaque on
peut jouer autour des 3 tours f3 par
exemple voilà donc les blancs semble
quand même avoir les mains libres pour
attaquer l'année 8 alors proposent
d'exercer une ici un contrôle sur les
cases sur ces cases là mais à cheval est
trop vite la tête évite simplement
regarder ici fou g5
voilà les cinq hommes on veut échanger
le fou pourquoi peut se caler sera
d'autant plus fort si ce fou et échanger
lecavalier va venir à m6 ou en d6 avec
une fois d'ailleurs aux menaces aussi
une fourchette en d6 pour prendre la
qualité mais il ya aussi la case et fils
qui sera faible pour le rat noir donc la
voyez les cases noires on joue sur les
cases noires c'est ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure en profite du fait que les
classes noirs sont faibles et on élimine
avec ce coup le dernier défenseur des
classes noir c'est à dire le foot 7 foot
prend cavale et prend alors évidemment
ça retarde un peu parce qu on est obligé
de reprendre du cavalier sur le garder
les dames avec l'attak bien entendu est
bon le câble quand même visage cette
visite c'est tout s'il peut y avoir des
thèmes mais si on veut revenir en 4 bien
voilà on va perdre un coup de plus donc
les noirs en profite pour jouer cavalier
à sec
voilà sans doute ce cas alors la fois un
jeu libère la possibilité pour la tour
de sortir mais aussi je fais aussi
sortira resserre à ces scènes d'ailleurs
et après je peux doubler les tours mais
aussi ceux cavale et pourra venir en c4
faisant une petite pression sur des six
mais aussi contrôler la classe des six
on a vu que la casse des cistudes classe
vous pouvez aller le cavaliere voilà le
cas il revient menaces aux cavaliers des
six fourchette qualité en plus
calais c'est cannes voilà juste à temps
on protège justement cette pièce des six
c'est une des autres idées du cavalier
seul et la tour des cas très bien pour
des cas on sait qu'on va jouer cavalier
six échecs tout le temps ou peut-être on
va revenir au g5 donc maintenant sept
tours va pouvoir qu'au lycée par exemple
en h4 et les menaces et les tours quand
je sais des choses comme ça moi g7
on va essayer de protéger lui-même les
casses faible et voilà tout re un bien
jouer maintenant on a fini le travail là
dessus on estime on vient mettre la tour
sur la colonne eux parce que cette tour
pourra envisager elle aussi devenir à
l'attaquant passant par 3,6 lequel les
bourgeois 4 et venir aller face au roi
noir h61 pierre cramier ça y est bon
mais elle a compris qu'il faut quand
même essayer de contrôler les cases
noires notamment pesci kyle et j5 h4 et
oui c'est le problème c'est que
maintenant il ya aussi le pion âge qui
vient d'attaquer dames c'est cette
tension menace la dame lecavalier menace
e5 d'un protège qu'une seule fois f4
alors f4 à la fois un avantage et un
inconvénient je protège au sein
définitivement mais j'abandonne toute
idée de faire coulisser la tour des
quatre mais je peuvent coulisser quand
même sur détroit je pourrais jouer par
exemple touré fin aussi autour des 3 si
je veux garder un contact sur le
cavalier c'est dire la protection je
pourrais jouer donc tour des 3 et venir
à coulisser soit en f3 soit en g3 b5 les
noirs ben ils essaient maintenant de
s'activer parce que ben là ça va ça va y
aller il me faut donc créer du contre
jeu c'était déjà trop tard h5 et
l'attaqué très forte
mais non c'est fini les blancs vont
ouvrir la colonne on peut plus
l'avantagent des f4 aussi voilà c'est
que ça contrôler un g5 peu plus mais on
peut même pas jouer g5 puisqu'on se
prend est proche des 5 ha je prends dans
prend et toutes les tombes voire même on
peut envisager de sacrifier le cavalier
et pourquoi pas être une attaque en plus
on peut aussi sacrifié samedi 8
donc c'est fini l'ouverture va se faire
tôt ou tard apprend béa prend b et mais
on se presse pas au regard des très
jolies dames j'ai quatre dames chez
quatre magnifiques tranquille voyez
pourquoi on lit vers la case d3 et on
aimerait bien qu'ils aient une tour là
parce que si on prend beya reprises puis
après comment on fait pour continuer il
vaut mieux avoir une tout ranger 3 tôt
ou tard pour augmenter la taxe dams et 7
qui permet éventuellement de mettre la
tour en g8 et le roi en fuite voilà une
défense comme ça en faisant coulisser le
roi c'est possible pour détroit quand
même et voilà donc j'évite la touche et
vite
c'est l'idée de ce coup dames c'est ton
mail à tous en g8
donc maintenant qu'a prise prise prises
et a même avec la tour en g3 bombay on
peut envisager simplement de jouer roi
trois fuites voilà doit s'en aller et la
qualif si c'est oui il y six attaques
l'attend j'évite 13e bien au bon goût et
bien joué de la part de boghni dahmani
fille tranquille elle a compris très
bien la position simplement on enlève
cette tour est bien dans l'entourage
suite forcé et touché trois là là ça
fait peur
alors on sent déjà intuitivement on doit
on doit se dire que ça semble fou tu
parce que il ya trop de pièces là le roi
est trop faible
il ya trop de pièces qui arrivent si
c'est énorme
il ya h prendre qui va arriver on voit
pas comment un noir peut s'en sortir
quelle attaque mais qu'elle attaque qui
nous a fait ici pour gone in a
tranquillement coup après coup on garder
comme l'a joué magnifiquement encore une
fois des partis datta khel et semble
extrêmement à l'aise dans les positions
de comme ça de d'initiative et d'attac
des cinq bien profite du fait qu'on peut
pas prendre en passant certainement
puisqu'il y aurait aidé à me prendre
cavaliers tout simplement hong est une
pièce mais c'est l'heure pour h prendre
les six étrangers 6dans prend airois f8
heureusement que la tour est là sinon
c'est et mat en g8 représente la tour
est venu quand même de ce côté mais l'on
joue en touche et 8 et le roi maintenant
alors le problème évident s'éclate
orages suite est isolé alors que les
pies les pièces blanches sont connectés
lamone les menaces ici à tout moment il
peut y avoir des menaces complémentaires
on peut enlever le cavalier on peut
jouer 5 5 est envisageable
aussi pour ouvrir des lignes f5
comprendre d'apprendre tout simplement
et on a un vis-à-vis
dames le roi avec avec une fourchette
enfin d'échec la découverte en tout cas
donc là ici les blancs jouent un coup
magnifique à regarder
on a trois pièces à l'attack laquelle
quelques cette attaque pas encore pour
créer on ne voit pas de menace directe
c'est en habile menaces directes
qu'indirectes on le ferait mais en y en
a plein direct il faut qu'à encore faire
des manoeuvres mais quand on a des
manoeuvres à faire comme ça qu'on est en
attaque il faut mettre un pied à enjeu
on attaque la pièce qui joue pas c'est
là qu'elle s'est bien évidemment la tour
1 nathan a fait son travail défensif et
offensif
elle est bien placé mais il faut qu'elle
vient d'un attaque simplement toi bien
sûr voilà un tourin menace 3,8 et c'est
fini c'est fini parce que y'a on peut
pas défendre comme geddo mais la dame et
ses mates locle à les noirs jouent le
seul coup en misérables alors c'est pas
tout à fait le seul on pouvait aussi
jouer qu'un v6 pour regarder on peut
enlever le cavalier ici
alors qu'est ce qui se passe si on
enlève le cavalier et bien sans doute
ont joué quand même
f5 voilà f5
c'est ce qu'on avait dit si on ouvre
aussi la colonne le fait que le cavalier
parti contrôle plus aux 5,5 et il reste
il reste encore des des menaces par
exemple sur dame f7 des noirs pour
essayer d'alléger la pression en
échangeant les dames c'est possible on
peut quand même prendre suisses ont
tranquillement dans me prends tout
reprendre et
simplement bon ramasse tout parce qu'en
fait ici donc on a de plus en plus qui
sont menaçants si les noirs on peut pas
jouer de recettes ce qui au retour j'ai
cet échec ramasse la tour et on peut
envisager des tours à 5 pour prendre b5
et des saintes si le cas est les bulls
où tour à 8 et c'est toujours pareil on
perd la tourache 8 voilà tout simplement
des choses comme ça mais les noirs
jouent à notre cou qui va être encore
plus radicale c'est à dire qu'ici tour à
cette empêche simplement la tour d'aller
y en a 8 d'accor
hélas les blancs jouent ils gagnent un
coup pas facile à voir et qui provoque
la bande en direct depuis accra ming
extraordinaire partie d'attac magnifique
regardez la puissance des blancs face au
noir visuellement le tableau est quand
même très beau je vous le fais
maintenant qu'à valider cet échec
blum c'est énorme alors ce cavalier
coupe connexion entre tours et dames de
toute façon il ya échec et le roi n'a
pas de case puisque tout est contrôlé
par la dame noire par l'adam pardon
blanche
il faut donc prendre soin de la dame
soit de la tour si on prend de la dame
l'idée est la suivante c'est simplement
d'ahmed six échecs la tour contrôle j'ai
donc il faut venir en 8es simplement je
prends ensuite et a pris 3,7 qui est
forcé il ya simplement un math angers
cet échec et mat puisque 85 contrôler
les deux cases de fuite du roi par là
donc c'est matt faut prendre de la dame
implique le mat direct si on prend
maintenant de la tour qui voit deux
possibilités
regardez simplement maintenant bien sûr
la tour est libéré donc ont fait tour à
huit échecs tour paraît le roi n'a
toujours pas de casque on va pas donner
la dame si nos ambitions en plus si on
fait en 81 matchs si on vient en des
huit avec la dame
on a donné la dame et puis on s'est bien
rattrapé de toute façon et si on joue
tour ici des huit simplement regarder
tout reprend d'un prends tes d'alger cet
échec ramasse la tour et puis la
deuxième tour va venir on va gagner
là vous le fait rapidement 3,8 d'emprunt
échec
trois des sept tours échec juste à temps
roy ses huit pour à la fois empêché les
chèques protéger la dame mais on perd en
plus la dame puisqu'on fait tour g8
et voilà on rahnasto donc on peut même
pas s'en sortir avec une qualité on perd
tout quoi en fait voilà donc superbe
feinte d'attac un magnifique ici l'a pas
vu sapiac running sursis à lui calé 17
alors quand même joué sans doute le
cavalier b6 comme on l'a vu mais on l'a
vu de toute façon ça ne suffit pas
l'attaquer déjà gagnante
les noirs ont joué trop passivement
cette ouverture
ils ont peut-être pas accepter
simplement de prendre l'option c3 au
début c'est peut-être un problème c'est
que quand souvent quand on se prend
comme ça une attaque rapide un
développement rapide il faut accepter de
prendre du matériel parce que ça permet
parfois de le rendre ce matériel plus
tard et d'équilibrer le jeu voilà et
donc la magnifique fin de partie et donc
magnifique retour en ce qu au score en
troisième retour au score d'affilée pour
pogo nina qui revient comme ça en
championnat du monde trois fois de suite
c'est extraordinaire c'est magnifique ce
que nous fait la russe elle revient en
8e et en quarts alors revient en demie
et là maintenant
c'est c'est un match qui qui va s'avérer
extrêmement intéressant à suivre pour
les tie-breaks est ce que bonnie dav a
encore une fois laissé l'adversaire
marquer avant de revenir je sais pas
c'est un peu déçu pour pierre cros bling
puisqu'elle n'était pas loin d'atteindre
une finale de championnat du monde
l'appareil était championne du monde un
pic roaming si on regarde le palmarès
donc c'était peut-être une chance pour
elle d' essayer d'atteindre ce
championnat du monde c'est encore
possible bien sûr mais maintenant ça
devient plus compliqué tie break la
fatigue aidant est ce que la jeunesse de
pau nina va pas jouer en sa faveur
question résistance physique aussi bien
sûr ça va jouer
voilà donc très intéressant à suivre
dans l'autre demi finale bien entendu eh
bien on donne aux résultats c'est à dire
que arica a fait match nul malgré un
pion de plus dans une finale deux tours
technique mais c'étaient les pions du
même côté quasiment impossible à gagner
donc match nul entre arica et nous y
trouve donc là aussi on aura droit à des
tie-breaks donc deux tie breaks pour les
demi finales de ce championnat du monde
2015 féminin voilà merci d'avoir suivi
sur canal tv à une prochaine fois tu
renvoies